oh [ __ ] you're at the right place
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] what a way to [ __ ]
attend the Lord's Day huh
hurricanes tornadoes white people
running and now yokel Joey
[Music]
[ __ ] and [ __ ] a goldfish swam around
the toilet that's how good the sushi is
that fresh fish cleaning cleaning the
[ __ ] sandwiches too bad for you when
you were over at the sand
you can tell they grind it up and put
dog bones of this [ __ ] and eyeballs you
go to sushi dad clean 100% of the famous
strikes on the [ __ ] salmon you're
[ __ ] crazy
there's another place on the door
and bring you here for that reason every
word is called white there's something
okay
delicious delicious delicious the
performance by the screen and a fight
that I yell done with some of these
three eight minutes that's just who you
wanna be
[Music]
that's how you got a Sunday night
started [ __ ] uncle Joey here
feeling very jealous a quoi my heart
goes out to Florida but the storm is
down to a two so we'll be all right you
know I'm saying you'll be swimming
around and [ __ ] for a few days the
power's out but hey listen it could have
been a lot worse
remember like I told you this morning no
matter how bad the situation is there's
always a silver lining maybe when the
water drains you'll find a half a
million in cocaine money that the narcos
left there by mistake you never [ __ ]
know besides that it's a cool chic
umlaut type at night it's a highway to
hell tight but now we got these things
look at this these two hundred
milligrams we got [ __ ] bags of stars
we got rods dude reefer
that's it it don't get no better than
that on a Sunday night you understand me
this periscope is sponsored by my bookie
let me tell you something [ __ ]
you wanna bet you don't know how to bet
what good is it having a winning team if
you're not gonna get paid that's why I
come in and I hook you up with my bookie
okay you tell him I sent you and they'll
match the [ __ ] crazy suppressant
Church CH you are CH and watch what
happens
if you put a nickel in they match the
[ __ ] nickel where you gonna get that
tie back you know I'm just trying to
tell you [ __ ] cuz I know you're
gonna bet anyway the weed I got tonight
is [ __ ] deadly it's from Ron's dude
no labels on it look at this [ __ ] this
one's got like an old label on this
stuff was so beautiful it was [ __ ]
glowing in the dog you have weed that
clothes the dog that's that's what I'm
talkin about in people it's time you
pack your bags and headed to the [ __ ]
California and waited for the earthquake
like all of us or they get hit by the
[ __ ] crazy Kareem you understand me
does the crazy Koreans don't light a
firecracker make a mistake California
nothing's been happening lately but
would do for something and I'm ready you
understand that we have to earthquake
kit we got the missile kit we got
everything anyway besides that let's
smoke a little reefer that's why
everybody's looking cake quickly showing
up [ __ ] looking good as usual [ __ ]
Savage oh [ __ ] would they beat the rent
look at that holy [ __ ]
39th and three we got ourselves a
football team okay Quigley which one's
old way coming from the party
no what's he do
[Music]
yeah Paul took it you that's why I love
you something you should be ashamed of
yourself Li ke Quigley comes prepared
for war she don't [ __ ] around with me
not the best thing about the churches
they know you want to bring a jeep Bo
and snort it you can do it give this
family a jeep overruled your couple
lines on the podcast you can do who
gives a [ __ ] at this point in the game
Snoop Dogg smokes weed like a [ __ ]
is a millionaire you smoke a joint they
won't hire you for a movie how
hypocritical is how hypocritical is it
Snoop Dogg has made 80 million dollars
and smoking weed and one of the smoked a
joint and we won't get hired for a
[ __ ] movie on TV
[Music]
well they can't go to ABC Family because
something a little monkey between your
legs ABC family don't want you on there
for Burton there [ __ ] can you imagine if
you'da bumped into Britney Spears and
she was 17 he would have done - I know
you wanna lift a little monkey she would
have flipped around right now you would
have had three [ __ ] kids after the
Chinese or something [ __ ] millionaire
you can adopted three kids and black one
like [ __ ] Angelina and this is how
you do it man this is how you do it
[ __ ] look at this she showed up
[Music]
you got a cup do we got a [ __ ] cup we
got twenty cups in Stanley Cups our
middle [ __ ] name [ __ ] Joey Cup [ __ ] a
little gin and juice in this
[ __ ] so beautiful now you'd open
up that door we got to [ __ ] now my
little hot princess and here's another
he has risen Jesus Joseph and [ __ ]
Mary I love it tonight basil I'm talking
about tequila bong it's [ __ ] stars of
death we got [ __ ] TKO you might as
well start doing those right now they
stop let's go wait [ __ ] around
celebrity TKOs
yeah yeah give you a little peace can
get the party started Cherokee Casino at
Shilla womp Springs next weekend one
show Saturday night so you better make
sure you're that [ __ ] I'm late
you know and don't forget I just put
that link up for my niece she's 18 she's
got the cancer if you give her a [ __ ]
dollar it would be phenomenal and you'd
be helping me out I'm gonna raffle off
my Longest Yard shirt I'm gonna do a
bunch of stuff for her she's only 18
well y'all me good
she's my brother's daughter he's not
just my brother he's you know like I
told you there's a silver lining to
everything look at this [ __ ]
[Music]
[ __ ] around here this transmission
fluids on fire tonight you understand me
[Music]
what are you gonna do all you could do
is [ __ ] try and behave yourself but
if we're gonna go deep we're gonna go
deep
it's that simple we can always show up
here playing game to you guys I wish you
could smell this stuff I wish you could
smell this transmission fluid it really
is this is from one of those narco cars
they took the transmission fluid out and
dip them into these edibles this is my
Bible it slides right down your throat
like when you come to somebody's mouth
near a toast our just it's just shoots
down a [ __ ] throat you'll even though
it's shot down it I can't believe you
came in my mind even feeling so good if
you don't feel it didn't happen you
complained it sucked off a lot of life
and enjoy that [ __ ] only how
many stars are going played 10 10 5 yeah
yeah we got a [ __ ] subsidize him
besides it's time for Ibaka to loosen up
your lungs you know I'm saying you
haven't been doing a bong hit sorry
[Music]
Chuchu
don't forget Saturday night Cherokee
Casino Oklahoma we ain't [ __ ] around
with bringing the pain down there show
up we're gonna have a good [ __ ] time
great new casino great [ __ ] food here
we go
what
he'd only sciatica nice for you unless
there's somebody else in the room namely
sciatica
[Music]
here we go you bad [ __ ] this is
the Ross dude we look back tip your head
back the blood work the lungs
[Laughter]
[Music]
it's the one that's the one Charlie sent
you guys let's go there you go that's
the one that Charlie sent you delicious
tip-top Magoo [ __ ] gay then a
yard here with uncle Joey and bong hits
I never a [ __ ] choice
if you're here with us you gotta do that
[ __ ] bondage huh there's not never a
trace like communist Cuba you walk in
you're doing a tuluyan thing will you do
a shot
tequila speaking of Cuba my hearts go
out to you [ __ ] you done to
Tovar come away is done a van is done
I've been trying to get ahold of my
sister ain't nobody pick it up so much
Asian guy picks up the phone and [ __ ]
the phone got transferred to a Chinese
that's what's going on in my [ __ ]
world people beside that we're here
we're queer we got nice podcast feed
tonight my [ __ ] sweetheart of love
this here cake Quigley niggly and my
[ __ ] main man the Christ killer the
first one ever
mr. Lee sciatica
[Music]
he's verified he will he's not a [ __ ]
christ-killers if you go to Twitter it
says [ __ ]
verified you don't say yeah they ain't
no [ __ ] half a [ __ ] christ-killers
here with samples on walking around
though their goal for his kills are
confirmed you're saying like that guy on
HBO what's the doodle play to do with
the sniper American sniper whatever I'm
loving it [ __ ]
I'm gonna get this little party started
up soon here Kate's gonna talk to us
about her last adventure in Vegas when
she got chlamydia and God knows what
else she she got chlamydia on her toe so
it was all over with this yeah some guy
came out of feet that's what happens
when people come on your feet you gotta
be careful
[Music]
great for another bond Headley this is
the [ __ ] I got Rosie Perez smoked before
do the right thing you follow me that's
how it it's got me
[Music]
good night it looks like that guy on CNN
in Florida - [ __ ] can't see him touch me
[Music]
that full report on CNN they couldn't
pay me enough he was out there all day
in the rain [ __ ] so so but one guys on
the balcony in Tampa Florida hold on
tight [ __ ] better days are
coming oh [ __ ] here we go
oh [ __ ] no save us for next Tuesday yeah
take it right now there's people in
Florida drowning to death and you want
to know if you should take a shot at the
Keeling [ __ ] [ __ ] pure savagery clay
Quigley are you crazy - what I know I
can tell you're jumping up and down
don't be a [ __ ] scary night for cake
please
here we go [ __ ]
oh [ __ ]
[Music]
Motz people the [ __ ] is to lend this out
one of my favorite all five [ __ ]
hours when I favor longtime slump the
double combo walk into you touch too
much angus is maybe 21 are you [ __ ]
kidding me
what
tremendous just [ __ ] today
I love all this [ __ ] understand that
this brings me back you got a
lightweight we'll play one more song off
this out I'm gonna get this podcast ah
they just take Quigley's legs about the
for each other quickly mix play
something I don't know if you've ever
seen a woman dancers if you've ever gone
to a strip club
you can request if you see a badass
chick in a club go to the DJ time to
play this if a woman could dance to this
you have to see when a woman could dance
for this song it is
oh there's two jams and if a woman could
dance to rock music this is rock music
this isn't made for dancing but when a
stripper comes out and dances it is or
the girl and the wrestler came out for
that scorpion song that was really
creepy at the end that song if a girl
could come out for this that's the girl
you want take home if the girl could
create a dance for this when a girl
comes out right here it starts right
there she just comes out real [ __ ]
high strolling takes off one thing the
other thing yeah I only have you that's
the only one of the dance I'm polish
you can take a pole dancing classes you
didn't good at it no strippers don't
like idiot savants they can't do nothing
but they could do that pole they've been
directly to what do you got to do what's
the [ __ ] truth on my head or soul my
body oh [ __ ] did somebody say start our
rat runs down the alley
[Music]
you wish the Sun would shine gonna yell
attack till you don't feel that til it's
hanging out your back of your fella
oh [ __ ]
[Music]
ago we say
[Music]
that's a doublet we got one two three
four five g's with
[Music]
yummy for your [ __ ] tongue B that's
how we're doing it in tonight I got some
chocolates for us in the bag Lisa yeah
we ain't [ __ ] around tonight it's a
it's a no would start in a week with a
[ __ ] bang it a lot of people been
slipping lately we didn't see you last
week cuz a [ __ ] Labor Day but this
Monday you're back like a [ __ ] Savage
understand me anyway youtube.com slash c
/ Joey D replace the [ __ ] be
Jack and don't forget next Saturday
night 8 p.m.
Cherokee Indian casino down there and
solo arm Springs myself and cake Quigley
we're gonna rock your [ __ ] world so I
don't give a [ __ ] where you're driving
from get that truck and tell Bubba let's
fill up the [ __ ] gas tank we're going
to [ __ ] charity
we'll go in a [ __ ] Oklahoma it's all
over
[Music]
nobody exactly two
then a flannel shirts on man just picked
you up rip your [ __ ] panties off rip
that [ __ ] to shred your [ __ ] nuts
anyway youtube.com slash see Justin
slash Joey Diaz listen without your
[ __ ] we got nothing
don't forget don't make the Harvey
donate the money whatever you could do
everybody's getting it from all
different directions that time of year
what are you gonna do I'm saying
youtube.com slash c / Joey D is the
place to be don't forget to go to my
bookie put in church and get [ __ ] max
whatever you put in there why [ __ ]
that one is if you can't collect it I'm
saying I donate [ __ ] everything you
buy the [ __ ] that's why I love you
don't forget I'll see you guys during
the week podcasters start in 10 minutes
[Music]